difficile de trouver plus paisible plus
charmant au lac comme à la montagne que
le vermont la mecque du pioneer le
paradis de la chasse dans l'interminable
débat sur le contrôle des armes à feu
le vermont est devenu un symbole ici la
fascination pour les armes comment
jeunes très jeunes tous les mercredis
après l'école les enfants des environs
de pau kenzy est au rendez vous au club
de tir à 8 ans justin suit les traces de
son père qui lui aussi a appris à tirer
ici quand il était petit c'est une
tradition sacrée les structures en chef
à wana surveille ses élèves de près
maître de la précision
mais avant tout de la vigilance
plusieurs ont déjà une arme à la maison
le vermont n'impose pas d'âge minimum
posséder un fusil et s'il faut avoir 21
ans pour acheter de la bière à 16 ans
les adolescents ou le droit d'acheter
une arme à feu légalement sans le
consentement de leurs parents
des 320 marchand d'armes certifié par le
fédéral au vermont il a ouvert son gun
shot à la campagne dans le sous sol de
sa maison il y à 57 ans ces affaires
n'ont jamais été aussi bonnes
gracieuseté dit-il du président obama à
tourner tout parce que chaque fois que
le président promet lui-même mesures de
contrôle dit et les clients prennent
panique et achètent ou vermont il
n'existe presque aucune restriction
suffit de passer la vérification en
ligne des antécédents criminels du fbi
et en dix minutes
la transaction est complétée les clients
refusent et peuvent se tourner vers
internet et acheter particulier le ver
money et posent aucune vérification
judiciaire et même pas besoin de permis
pour porter son arme à la ceinture ou
vermand une liberté extraordinaire qui
n'avait jamais vraiment été remise en
question
mais le carnage à l'école syndicaux
copenhague est en 2012 a changé la donne
enbridge une mère au foyer ça complet
smaghi cassidy une enseignante à la
retraite sont partis de riez elle
sillonne les campagnes pour sortir
distel la population de son mutisme
on est arrivé à confondre la la chasse
la prod ex de la protection de sa
famille avec l' accès total aux armes à
feu
leur organisme gones sense en a fait du
chemin comme obliger les tribunaux de
rapporter les cas grave de maladie
mentale
mais ce n'est qu'une toute petite
victoire elle continue de se battre pour
des vérifications universel maggie casse
des sondages à l'appui dit qu'une
majorité silencieuse au vermont en
souhaite autant comme son mari qui a
toujours eu me fusiller à la maison je
ne suis pas anti art mais j'ai très peu
je peux le dire j'ai très peu peur tu es
de la porte et me brun n'importe où
n'importe quand
norman blais ancien conseiller municipal
à burlington a lui aussi osé contester
la nord c'est lui qui a mené la charge
quand la mairie a voté en 2013 pour
bannir les armes à feu des bars de la
ville
depuis trois ans plus tard rien n'a
changé parce que la constitution de
l'état interdite à toute municipalité de
réglementer les à une fusillade mortelle
devant ce bar vient de relancer la
bataille et elle est intense
deux des citoyens comme head coach le un
grand passionné des armes montent aux
barricades chaque fois qu'une
proposition est à l'étude il a fondé les
gunners du vermont le lobby pro armes
par excellence il fait fièrement la
démonstration du type d'armes d'assaut
que le vermont n'a jamais banni malgré
de nombreuses tentatives
et quand on lui demande pourquoi ne pas
limiter l'accès ne serait ce que pour
réduire les risques de violence et le
trafic d'armes
son ami bob les patients invoque le
deuxième amendement se lève
pourtant il mettre fin à l' échange le
débat est à ce point i motifs et
viscérale tout un paradoxe ce vermont un
état si progressiste ou même les
démocrates défendent leurs armes et
leurs copains
et ça personne ne l'incarnent aussi bien
que son plus célèbre politicien bernie
sanders candidat à l'investiture
démocrate a souvent voté du même côté
que la nd aujourd'hui ambivalent il se
rallie au président obama dans l'état le
plus armé de l'amérique
c'est un début le mythe selon lequel le
contrôle des armes à feu et un sujet
intouchable qui peut démolir tout
politicien qui aux enfers une croisade
ma guy cassoly n'y croit plus on
n'aurait pas en parler finalement les
armes étaient sacrés au plan les gens
osent parler aussi petit et discret
qu'il soit le vermont est au coeur d'un
débat que les américains ne peuvent plus
ignorer cela on a tellement pas
l'habitude de penser au vermont sous cet
angle là mais aux états unis qu'est ce
que ça représente pour le lobby pro à
il est devenu vermont une référence ans
voilà la preuve un état où tout est
permis qui est armé jusqu'aux dents et
où le taux d'homicide est un des plus
bas au pays mais le problème c'est que
pendant ce temps-là de plus en plus
d'états comme le texas l'a fait
récemment réclame devant les tribunaux
le même genre de liberté c'est légal
depuis quelques semaines par exemple au
texas et en alaska de se promener avec
une arme à la ceinture non dissimulé
l'autre problème c'est le trafic des
armes à feu celles qui sont achetés
facilement au vermont qui on retrouve de
plus en plus sur des scènes de crime à
bostens et à new york et qui explique
pourquoi des politiciens comme michael
bloomberg l'ancien maire de new york
finance les petits groupes que vous avez
vues dans le reportage pour leur donner
les moyens au moins de tenir tête ou
très puissant lobby des armes à feu et
on peut dire que ce qui a peut-être d'
encourageant c'est que ça s'impose ce
débat là maintenant dans la campagne
présidentielle et ça c'est déjà une
grande avancée c'est une toute petite
victoire mais c'est la première fois et
ça tout le monde le dit aux états unis
que de façon aussi claire la question
des armes à feu s'impose dans une course
à la maison blanche
donc un petit pas encourageant merci aux
big notamment au revoir